S
AND BASICALLY RODE A PIECE
SAYING HE'S HAVING A REALLY HARD
TIME OUT THERE ON STAGE.
>> WELCOMING BACK TO THE PANEL,
WE TALK ABOUT DEBATES, HAD THE
OCTOBER 25TH DEBATE HAD BEEN
SEPTEMBER 30TH.
WITH THIS RACE HAVE CHANGED?
>> I THINK IT WOULDN'T.
THERE IS A BROADER ISSUE AND
THINK ABOUT THIS, WE HAD THE
WORST INFLATION IN FOUR DECADES.
THE WORST CRIME WAVE SINCE THE
1990s WITH THE WORST BORDER
CRISIS IN U.S. HISTORY HERE WE
HAD JOE BIDEN WHO'S THE LEAST
POPULAR PRESIDENT SINCE
HARRY TRUMAN SINCE PRESIDENTIAL
POLLING HAPPENED AND THERE
WASN'T A RED WAVE.
THAT IS A SEARING INDICTMENT OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THE MESSAGE WE HAVE BEEN SENDING
TO THE BORDERS WHERE THEY LOOKED
AT ALL OF THAT, AND LOOKED AT
REPUBLICAN ALTERNATIVE AND SAID
NO THANKS.
THAT IS -- THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
NEEDS TO DO A REALLY DEEP IN
PERSPECTIVE LOOK IN THE MIRROR
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTE DISASTER FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND WE NEED TO
TURN BACK.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT WHO WON
TODAY.
RON DeSANTIS.
MIKE DeWINE.
THESE GOVERNORS.
KEMP.
>> ABBOTT.
>> THESE ARE THE PATH TO THE
FUTURE.
ELECTING THESE, YOU KNOW, THESE
RADICAL CANDIDATES WHO RAN FAR
BEHIND THEM HAVE PUT THE